wir melden uns nochmal zurück aus
osterhofen und bei der afg und ihren
politischen aschermittwoch und wie
versprochen zeigen denen jetzt die rede
des bundesvorsitzenden und
spitzenkandidat für die europawahl jörg
merten meine sehr geehrten damen und
herren hochverehrte anders
geschlechtliche werte medienvertreter
liebe v-leute und geschätzte prüfen das
ist noch nicht ganz vollständig die
soaps unter uns der andreas kalbitz zum
beispiel dass ein bisschen snob er
besteht darauf er hat es gehört
verdachtsfall zu sein und nicht nur ein
ordinärer prüfer also auch liebe
verdachtsfälle aber aber wenn wir im
abschluss gleich zu beginn so darf ich
jedoch gar niemand bezeichnen die wir
seit letzter woche wissen so ein jammer
aber auch für so manchen politisch
übermotivierten schlapphut allen voran
für ein halten man offensichtlicher
liebe freunde war politische
instrumentalisierung einer staatlichen
behörde noch selten und es wird immer
schlimmer
jetzt lässt der haldenwang wie ich höre
muss das noch prüfen aber es scheint zu
stimmen prüfen ob es afd mitglieder oder
sympathisanten der afd
in den reihen des verfassungsschutzes
gibt und es wird wohl auch überprüft ob
die leute die da arbeiten eventuell afd
menschen in ihrem privaten umfeld haben
genau das was ich genau das was ich hier
höre daran denke ich auch das erinnert
mich tatsächlich auf eine fatale art und
weise an stasi methoden
das ist aller fensters und habe mir
freiheitliche demokratie nichts zu tun
das alles kann man sich ja sowieso nicht
ausdenken
nach monaten intensiver prüfung unserer
partei schon zu maßen zeiten wurde
geprüft kommen die nach ihm die lange
geprüft haben zum ergebnis ihr seid ein
prüfer das muss man sich mal überlegen
dreifacher tus obwohl sie genau das sind
wir haben das gerichtlich feststellen
lassen und über diesen erfolg dieser
woche habe ich mich wirklich gefreut
das dürfen die gar nicht feststellen
jedenfalls nicht öffentlich
und so wird der pool fall für den
verfassungsschutz zum reinfall
ein richtiger reinfall der
verfassungsschutz wenn das so weitergeht
wird wahrscheinlich noch selber zum fall
für den verfassungsschutz befreundet
dass es das ist deutschland im jahr 2009
10 werden zunehmend zu einer art
bananenrepublik allerdings einer ohne
bananen dafür aber mit politikern die
inzwischen den berufsstand der satiriker
entbehrlich machen
wer braucht um alles in der welt doch
olli welke und die heute show
wenn man ganz real einen ralf stegner
von der spd hat ich muss auf den herren
auch eingehen der macht die heute-show
entbehrlich sie wissen schon der pöbel
reihe aus bordesholm
das ist der herr mit dem ungemein
sympathischen und gewinnenden lächeln
über den forsa chef und spd mitglied
auch das ist bemerkenswert manfred
güllner sich wie folgt äußert zitat er
wird mit verlaub von den menschen als
kotzbrocken wahrgenommen
mit verlaub herr grüner ich habe ihnen
soweit ich mich erinnern kann noch in
absolut nichts die zugestimmt
hier aber mach ich dann gerne mal eine
ausnahme und die sympathie und
hoffnungsträger stegner ist
hoffnungsträger
das meine ich ganz ernst wir tragen
nämlich die hoffnung in uns dass er der
spd noch sehr lange erhalten bleibt
der war jetzt auch noch so liebenswert
das hat der berner auch schon mal
zitiert ich werde noch einmal zitieren
weil das wirklich wichtig ist weil das
das deutlich macht was hier passiert
dass sie auf twitter folgendes
geschrieben hat ich zitiere die
rechtspopulisten von der ard kommen
endlich in den fokus des
verfassungsschutzes
dazu musste der unselige herr maßen
gehen damit das passieren kann was
längst überfällig war dazu da kann man
doch nur sagen ralf stegner ein name ein
geständnis ich kenne eine liste mit
namen von leuten die alle schlauer sind
als stegner diese liste nennt sich
telefonbuch liebe freunde
nun könnte man ja denken na ja für die
spalte spezial demokraten kann es
schlimmer nicht mehr kommen und der
pöbel rallye ist vielleicht nur eine
ausnahme in dem laden aber nein das wäre
zu optimistisch gedacht
man schaue sich die reihen der roten
wirklich mal genauer an so lange die
noch genug personal für eine ganze reihe
haben da ist etwa der gerade zu
südländisch anmutende temperamentsbolzen
olaf scholz der als regierender
bürgermeister von hamburg den ganzen g20
gipfel fenster belohnt wurde diese
leistung in anführungsstrichen mit dem
finanzministerium und der vizekanzler
schafft spd das ist wirklich die
perfektionierte negativ auslese liebe
freunde und wenn scholz dieser begnadete
in den sand setzte jetzt auch noch die
finanzen des bundes an die wand fährt
und er hat schon begonnen damit müsste
ja voll gericht die ich fast schon die
kanzlerschaft winken ihr traut er sich
dann auch durchaus zu wie wir wissen da
die bild titelte etwa olaf scholz will
kanzler werden
bedrohungen von einer zeitung
54 widersprüche meinrad lieber g20
verantworte olaf scholz g 20 minuten in
dich und fragt ich mal ob du das
wirklich ganz dann merkst du schon
selbst nein das kannst du nicht nie im
leben kannst du da die natürliche
kanzlerkandidatin der genossen also
falls die noch so was wie einen
kanzlerkandidaten überhaupt aufstellen
was ja schon kühn ist ist ja
bekanntermaßen so wieso jemand anderes
andrea nahles
wer sonst die fleischwerdung der
glaubwürdigkeit die personifizierung des
fein geschliffenen wortes pure grandezza
eine parteivorsitzende deren filigrane
ja geradezu fein ziselierte rhetorik
sich in der feinsinnigen ankündigung
vollendete der cdu künftig in die fresse
geben zu wollen
ja so spricht für die andrea nahles
mithin nebenbei jener partei mit der
wenigen gerne monate später gar nicht
schnell genug gehen konnte ins
koalitionsbett hin zu rücken
und natürlich meinen sie auch sie kann
kanzlerin
und lässt das volk das wissen hat sie
versichert mehr hybris liebe freunde war
selten weil es der sinn der realität
verteilt wurde
da hat andrea nahles gerade verstecken
gespielt anders kann man sich das nicht
erklären und so roth nun all die
hoffnungen der genossen auf ihrer partei
und ihrem capo klein kevin sie wissen
schon meint kevin kühnert das von rot es
ausgerechnet so ein kevin kühnert gilt
heute als letzte hoffnung der spd also
genau der menschentyp er wie kein
anderer für die entfremdung der
einstigen partei der malocher von ihrer
eigentlichen klientel steht
denn das was der andreas eben gesagt da
ist völlig richtig genau das ist der
fall
die sind so meilenweit davon entfernt
nie richtig gearbeitet hat dieser junge
mann kein linker handwerksburschen
nichts fertig studiert trotzdem ein
flinker mundwerks bursche social media
sozi gestellt entweder gewittern
das perfekte sinnbild für den niedergang
der partei politisch organisierten
sozialdemokratie und reingewinn jusos
aktg 1 kevins juso gruppe hat auf ihrem
bundeskongress da hat es dann wirklich
auch noch spaß sich zu sein
ernsthaft die legalisierung der
abtreibung bis zum neunten monat
beschlossen
das haben sie beschlossen und die
mutterpartei hat nicht widersprochen
also nichts geringeres wurde da
beschlossen als die legalisierung von
kindsmord solange es sich nur noch im
mutterleib befindet und wenn es einen
tag vor der geburt ist das sind im
übrigen die selben leute die es bereits
schöne menschenrechtsverletzungen
herhalten wenn eine migranten zur
altersfeststellung der handwurzelknochen
bereinigt werden soll
so sieht das aus bei denen
[Applaus]
das sind da kommt jakob diese doppelung
rhein mit andreas kalbitz neben mir viel
hier nicht auch wenn die musste auch ein
paar worte sagen das sind auswüchse
einer denke für diesen fachbegriff gibt
an tina tallis muss nennt sich das an
tina was werden sie fragen an tina
tallis muss eine philosophie die sich
dafür ausspricht keine neuen menschen in
die welt zu setzen
warum darf eine gruppe britischer frauen
klärt uns auf
man wolle aus angst vor dem klimawandel
keine kinder in die welt setzen
zitat unser planet befindet sich derzeit
am kollabieren sagt die sprecherin der
gruppe börse zu deutsch gebärt streik
gesagt wir haben einen partner den sie
liebe und mit dem wir eigentlich gerne
auch kinder haben würde findet sich
alles prima an aber nach der lektüre des
berichtes des weltklimarates habe sie
realisiert ich zitiere wieder wie falsch
es wäre ein kind in die welt zu setzen
die am rande der katastrophe steht eine
deutsche feministin hat jetzt gerade ein
buch geschrieben pflichtet ihr bei auch
das zitiere ich da wird es noch
gruseliger ein kind ist das schlimmste
was man der umwelt antun kann jedes
nicht in die welt gesetzte kind bedeutet
eine co2 einsparung von rund 50 tonnen
im jahr rechnet sie vor wo kein leben da
keine co2 emissionen
das ist logisch wo kein leben da keine
co2-emission
es drängt sich da oder ich finde den
gedanken mal fort ein wenig in der ganz
eigenen wirren logik dieser zeit
genossen die frage auf wenn aber die
bestehenden co2 emission wohlgemerkt in
deren folge ihrer logik bereits zu hoch
sind
ganz ohne neugeborene die ideologische
gebühr steigt also nicht reicht und die
böse klimakatastrophe abzuwenden
was dann nun man könnte ja nicht bloß
kein neues leben schaffen sondern als
nächstes der umwelt zuliebe gleich auch
bestehendes eigenes leben beenden öko
verträgliches und nachhaltiges
frühableben sozusagen suizid für die
klimarettung pro sozialismus als
konsequente ergänzung zum
martina tallis muss jetzt das ist
richtig pervers na ich für die gedanken
aber schon ganz charmant wenn die grünen
er immer die avantgarde der der ökologie
stellen wollen dann löst das ihnen wir
ziemlich interessanten gedanken aus sie
können auch hier mit gutem beispiel
vorangehen nur mal so eine idee wir mal
ehrlich diese idee mehr nichtmals der
visionär thilo sarrazin hat sein
legendäres buch schrieb deutschland
schafft sich ab aber der hat nicht daran
geschrieben zur klimarettung ich finde
das pervers weit getrost ich auch ich
finde das komplett bewerbs all das sind
die ergebnisse völlig verqueren
lebensfeindlichen und auch selbsthass
letztlich basierenden denken und wie wir
es klassisch im linken milieu seit
urzeiten antreffen und schaut euch
einmal an ich habe das nicht finanzieren
nicht groß ausführen aber achtmal auf
die kinderzahlen von menschen die aktiv
politik betreiben werden eben orban
er hat fünf kinder tram fünf kinder
strache österreich drei seiner linie 2
und ich könnte könnte die reihe
fortsetzen wir haben hier lauter
menschen mit vielen kindern ich selbst
bin auch vater von fünf kindern merkel
merkel 0 junker 000
die haben alle keine kinder und das
verändert das denken denn dann kommt man
tatsächlich zu skurrilen positionen
leichter als wenn man kinder reich ist
weil man dann eine ganz natürliche
präferenz für eine zukunft in diesem
land von youtube entfernt hat das ist
richtig
[Applaus]
wie auch immer während der linke kämpft
gegen das leben kaum thematisiert wurde
da fast zeitgleich die mit reichlich
steuergeld ordentlich gepampert amadeu
antonio stiftung
[Musik]
mehr davon mehr davon dass sie verdienen
dass eine broschüre heraus die dabei
helfen soll rechtsextreme eltern anhand
des aussehens ihrer kinder zu erkennen
kein letztes war ich sags ja immer zu
dieses land ist verrückt geworden
eine studie wo man erkennen soll anhand
des aussehens vergehen
ob die eltern vielleicht rechtsextrem
sind und das geht so wenn die söhne gut
gebaut und sportlich fit sind und die
töchter kleider und röcke tragen dann
ist das elternhaus vermutlich
rechtsextrem infiltriert und ich mutmaße
mal das ist für die leute wahrscheinlich
so mädchen mit einem zopf ein elternteil
nazi zwei kleine nazis ja so denken wie
das was mich nun wiederum ins grübeln
bringt was ist denn dann mit der kleinen
geräte aus schweden
zwei zöpfe was ist denn das für ein
elternhaus sind das dann etwa klima
nazis was ist das land diese geräte die
hat ja aus dem schule schwänzen eine
tugend gemacht
erfolge eine ganze armada öko politisch
korrekter kindersoldaten was da
geschieht liebe freunde das ist
politischer kindesmissbrauch und nichts
anderes als das
ich habe glücklicherweise der tochter
geht die geht in die sechste klasse und
die durchschaut das bereits und wenn die
anfangen bei uns haben werde ich darauf
bestehen mein unterricht zu bekommen und
ich sage und das machst du und wenn es
dann trotzdem freigeben sagte mir
bescheid herrn welcher mal vorstellen
alle finden also jetzt das
schuleschwänzen teuer
sogar die kanzlerin und auch
justizministerin bali kann man sich auch
nicht ausdenken andererseits bei den
maroden zustand unserer schulen
vielleicht auch nicht die schlechteste
idee nur das ist ja was mich so
erschreckt das ist das ausmaß der
indoktrination eine ganze jugend wird
von einer absurden ideologie hier
vereinnahmen die glauben dass wir
glauben dass die glauben wenn sie jetzt
wieder auf die straße gehen haben sie
keine zukunft weil die klimakatastrophe
kommt und der planet ist in wenigen
jahren kaputt die glauben dass wirklich
mit paragraf 9 des schulpflicht gesetzes
steht ein fernbleiben von der schule ist
während der schulzeit nur im falle
gerechtfertigter verhinderung des
schülers zulässig kanzlerin merkel aber
auch frau war von der spd und die große
mehrheit des polit establishments
unterstützen jedoch ganz offen das
kollektive schule schwänzen für die
kollektiv moralische selbstbefriedigung
merkel das ist der notorische drang zum
gesetzesbruch sie kann das einfach nicht
lassen nicht mal als darf
in anlehnung an den großen leider
kürzlich verstorbenen karl lagerfeld
könnte man sagen wer merkel wählt hat
die kontrolle über sein leben verloren
[Applaus]
das soll aber nicht heißen dass ich
dieser kontrollverlust auf die wahl von
merkel beschränkt es gibt er noch ein
paar andere politische akteure auf die
das zutrifft
und er hat es mit dem grünen heute schon
ich muss meinen teil auch dazu beitragen
ich habe zumindest ein paar zitate die
garantiert noch nicht vorkam
kleine kostprobe aus der grünen
gruselshow gefällig gerne hier mal ein
paar schlagzeilen
alles ohne von grünen bzw
von presse schlagzeilen über gründen
grüne wollen weihnachtsbaum vor
düsseldorfer rathaus abschaffen und
zeitgemäßes ritual grünen politiker
fordert bombardierung dresdens grüne
wollen keine in deutschland flaggen zur
em sehen grüne wollen spargel folien
verbieten provozierender tweet grüne
jugend wünscht sich erneute auflösung
deutschlands niedersachsens grüne justiz
ministerin verteidigt kinder ihn grünen
politiker ströbele will inzest erlauben
grüne fordern 6 auf rezept für
pflegebedürftige und so weiter und dann
gibt es da natürlich das sind alles
pressemeldungen über die grünen alle
tief bürgerliche partei wie und
vermittelt wird und dann gibt es
natürlich noch die evergreens von katrin
göring eckardt die ernsthaft sagt und
man kann den satz nicht oft genug
wiederholen ich habe ihn schon oft
gebracht willkommenskultur ist der beste
schutz vor terroristen
meine güte wenn diese frau schweigt was
ich viel öfter tun sollte dann meinen
alle sie ist auch intelligenz befreit
wenn sie aber redet dann sind sich alle
sicher das ist ja unfassbar
und fehlen darf natürlich auch nicht
robert habeck zitat vaterlandsliebe fand
ich stets zum kurzen mit deutschland
wusste ich nichts anzufangen und weiß es
bis heute nicht
parteivorsitzender der grünen er weiß es
bis heute nicht wissen es macht nicht
wissen macht auch nichts das ist die
beiden grünen aber das weiß keiner
besser als die ich sage dazu und
intelligenz kurzem von 150 supersache
blöd nur wenn sich die ganze partei
teilen muss liebe freunde
[Applaus]
und das beste das beste ist trotz all
dessen was ich jetzt hier gerade
berichtet habe über die grünen was man
überprüfen kann halten 55 prozent der
bürger dieses landes die grünen
mittlerweile für eine partei der mitte
bombardierung deutscher städte die
auflösung deutschlands der kampf gegen
die eigene tradition und kultur verbots
ismus kinder ihn legalisierung von
inzest und sex auf rezept
pflegebedürftig das sind auch so richtig
typisch bürgerlich wichtige position
sagt selbst man kann es nicht anders
sagen dieses land ist schon verrückt
geworden
diese ach so bürgerlichen achtmonatigen
grünen schrecken vor nichts zurück
auch nicht vor einem wirklich
durchgeknallten kulturgut gegen das auto
die von den grünen ein letztes zitat
dazu die von den grünen ins amt gehobene
berliner verkehrssenatorin regine
günther hat die katze aus dem sack
gelassen
zitat wir möchten dass die menschen ihr
auto abschaffen
nun machen wir also einen der letzten
noch verbliebenen standortvorteile ohne
not auch noch selbst kaputt eine
energiewende mit der ökologischen
brechen mit der ideologischen ökologisch
wäre ihn mit der ideologischen
brechstange bei gleichzeitiger
umstrukturierung auf extrem ressourcen
verschlingen die elektromobilität man
muss da mal die ökobilanzen übereinander
sehen da wird man sehen welche
technologie wirklich umweltschädlich ist
das muss und kann nur scheitern
aber macht ja nix die grünen wissen
immer roger kluge leute die rettung ist
nah kommt mal wieder von den
weltverbesserer an der grünen die wissen
nämlich ganz genau wie man energie spart
und dennoch arbeitsplätze schafft aus
den reihen der grünen kam auch ernsthaft
der vorschlag man könne doch esel taxis
einführen
ja
ernster das sind wurden aber die sind ja
innovativ das sind keine normalen esel
sondern sogenannte portugiese habe ich
auch erst lernen müssen die bringen vor
einen karren gespannt sage und schreibe
bis zu 24 stundenkilometer im schnitt
fünf bis sechs kilometer pro stunde
allerdings nur mit so einem porto esel
hätte ich zum beispiel von brüssel nach
osterhofen in starken 160 stunden
geschafft also vorausgesetzte esel hätte
mein gewicht ausgehalten was eher
unwahrscheinlich ist dagegen ist ein
euro 5 diesel natürlich langsam das ist
klar
ich habe das zunächst eine satire
gehalten ich will meinen mitarbeitern
rückversichert ob denn das stimmt und
das stimmt tatsächlich eine grüne
lokalpolitikerin aus der pfalz schlägt
solche esel taxis allen ernstes vor und
hält das für einen sinnvollen beitrag
zur achtung entschleunigung des lebens
ja so ist das mit den grünen wenn man
den der taschenlampen leuchten die augen
um glauben
[Applaus]
wem erzähle ich dass ich bin ich wieder
hier in bayern und ihr habt ihr hier
eure kerosin katar also grünen chefin im
landtag sitzen die munter mit der vom
verfassungsschutz beobachten
beobachteten marxistisch leninistischen
partei deutschlands gegen ein abschiebe
flug am franz josef strauß flughafen
demonstrierte auf dem die parolen feuer
und flamme den abschiebe behörden und
mord folter deportation dass es deutsche
tradition skandiert wurden es genau die
kerosin katar die das klima retten und
allen alles verbieten möchte allen voran
das autofahren die aber selbst um die
halbe welt mit dem flieger reist um in
kalifornien eis aus dem plastikbecher
mit einem plastiklöffel zu schlürfen und
dann zu ihrer verteidigung sagen wohl
mit weniger urlaub verbringen ist meine
privatsache nicht falsch dass das ihre
privatsache ist nur 14 damit den
kompletten verbots fetischismus ihrer
eigenen partei absurden und sagt für
mich gilt das nicht denn ich bin hier im
parlament
und genau solche leute habe ich da im
europäischen parlament massenweise
sitzen deswegen freue ich mir so dass er
jetzt viel mehr vernunft reinkommt denn
es wird zeit diese leute dazu fragen
dem volk das autofahren abgewöhnen
wollen aber selbst mit dem flieger zur
urlaubs zwecken nach kalifornien um dem
plastiklöffel zu schlüpfen dann muss man
erstmal drauf kommen
viel hat die von den 150 punkten die ich
eben erwähnte offensichtlich nicht
abbekommen als die am letzten parteitag
der grünen verteilt wurden ideale
voraussetzungen also um künftig mit der
union zu koalieren
wir haben ja einige bis vor kurzem noch
eine konservative wende zugetraut
ich werde sagen aber das war wohl nix
denn mit annegret kramp karrenbauer
ich habe lange gebraucht habe ich kann
den namen mittlerweile fließend
fehlerfreien als neuer parteichef in
wird weiter gemerkt wie bisher den
besten beweis dass die gewillt ist bis
zum bitteren ende weiter zu merken
erbracht der hkk also angelas kleine
kopie bereits
da geht es ja viele verulken ich habe
noch nicht einmal gesagt hkk steht für
afrika kommen also jetzt viele
möglichkeiten bereits ist aber schon alt
bereits anfang november das ihnen
schlimmste merkel spricht zur größten
aller merkel viele entscheidungen wie
folgt herumgewirbelt zitat und wenn man
glaubt man kann die diskussion führen
mit dem eindruck man könnte das was 2015
entschieden worden ist rückgängig machen
oder rückabwickeln da muss man glaube
ich ganz ehrlich sein
in die partei hinein über die partei
hinaus zu sagen das was 2015 passiert
ist ist realität ist ein fakt und kann
und wird nicht rückabgewickelt werden
zitat ende annegret kramp-karrenbauer
das ist nach der merkel devise nun ist
es heute passiert ja da kann man nichts
machen jetzt sind sie halt da nicht so
drucks diese merkel kopie herum jetzt
sind die goldstücke martin schulz und
fachkräfte eben dank merkel im land wen
kümmert es das schon dass die meisten
dieser einwanderer zu größten teilen
alimentiert werden müssen und zwar wenn
sie bleiben auf dauer weil sie nämlich
in unseren arbeitsmarkt nicht
integrierbar sind das heißt sie sind
hier als eine art sofort rentner ohne
hier eingezahlt zu haben vermutlich ein
leben lang und richtet man pausenlos ein
multikulti ist toll willkommen zu der
beste willkommenskultur der beste schutz
vor terroristen das was die flüchtlingen
uns bringen schmuggelte schuld sei
wertvoller als gold
ich frage mich dann nur wenn da wirklich
alles so toll ist wie so bestehen dann
die kartell parteien darauf die
migranten auf andere europäische länder
vor allem jene aus dem osten europas und
dann zb zu verteilen
müssten wir nicht orban kaczynski und co
geradezu dankbar dafür sein dass sie in
all ihrer bescheidenheit auf die vielen
goldstücke verzichten und die uns
überlassen
ja
[Applaus]
eine logik ist eine noble geste wie auch
immer kaka wird merkels politik für die
nächsten jahre ja jahrzehnte zu
zementieren versuchen sie wird die
illegalen einwanderern nicht des landes
verweisen wie wir die grenzen nicht
schließen gegen weiteren zustrom sie
wird in europa und der ganzen welt
weiterhin das checkpunkt der deutsche
steuerzahler zücken und sie wird die cdu
weiter sozialdemokratisiert und grüni
sieren sofern das überhaupt noch möglich
ist und so darf das auch nicht wundern
das finde ich jetzt auch eine schöne
pointe in unserem land in diesen tagen
das keine satire laut einer spiegel
-umfrage einer aktuellen spiegel
-umfrage grünen-wähler von aa kk
überzeugt da sind als unionswählern das
kann ich verstehen ja das verstehe ich
wirklich und es spricht bände dass die
cdu mittlerweile eine geradezu kultur
marxistischen partei ist erkennt man
aber auch daran dass wird paul 10 jagt
ein 33-jähriger ewig student weiß nehmen
wir 33 sollte man fertig sein oder ohne
abschluss und ohne sonstige berufliche
qualifikation nun zum generalsekretär
berufen worden ist kein unterschied mehr
zu den grünen und der spd da ist das
sowieso so ich finde immer witzig wenn
politiker dieser parteien ohne jeden
eigenen berufsabschluss die haben keinen
dann einen fachkräftemangel beklagen bei
denen allen schrieb fachliche
qualifikation überhaupt eine rolle aber
die beklagen sagt effkemann auch sinn
für humor und dieser zehn jahren
vertritt in der heutigen cdu angeblich
den konservativen flügel cdu das ist
heute dreiste kommen können
konservatismus simulation entschuldigung
und paul signac mit verlaub ist der
kevin kühnert für segel zu tragen dass
der einzige unterschied liefern tut die
union nichts gar nichts
man sieht ja was dabei rauskommt wenn
knallharte pseudo konservative
blendgranaten ein exemplarischer
seehofer und co in der bundesregierung
grenzschutz kompromisse aushandeln
wir konnten uns das jetzt lange
anschauen in sieben monaten
ausgehandelter kompromiss
wurden sage und schreibe elf
asylbewerber 11 an der einreise
gehindert 11 asylbewerber dürften nicht
einreisen
chapeau da hat der innenminister mal
wieder seinem namen ganz große ehre
gemacht er bleibt für alle zeiten unser
heißluft horst um das klarzustellen die
irre führende konservative rhetorik der
csu nützt nichts denn letztlich macht
die csu und das tut sie seit jeher all
das mit was die regierung zur wehr sie
nun auch mal seit jahren gehört zu
verantworten hat also auch die
herrschaft des unrechts die horste ja
selbst anprangerte die csu ist eben kein
konservatives bayerisches korrektiv der
rest union sondern der devote untertan
der kanzler domina so sieht das leider
aus und das ist immer noch 5 und wie es
stattdessen wirklich geht das zeigt uns
unterdessen matteo salvini in italien
262 262 migranten wanderten ersten zwei
monaten dieses jahres nach italien ein
ganz frische zahlen einen rückgang um
sage und schreibe 95 prozent und
zugleich wird viermal so viele
abgeschoben worden
viermal so viele raus man kann er recht
statt also walten lassen
man kann also die eigene bevölkerung
schützen
man kann offensichtlich salvini zeigt
dass illegale migration stoppen
man muss das nur wollen unsere regierung
will das aber nicht sie behaupten dass
unterdessen aber sie wollen es nicht
denn sonst hätten sie ist genauso wie
die italiener es inzwischen tut sie tun
es nicht
und statt eines matteo salvini haben wir
eben heute die damen bekamen heute auch
schon vor eine ursula von der leyen
verteidigungsministerin eines landes mit
schrottreifen panzern und allerlei
rostigen flug untauglichen kampfjets
ideales equipment für gefühlt 50
auslandseinsätze ja die ursel die
schäden wenig im fadenkreuz der kritik
und das nicht ganz zu unrecht
stichwort berater affäre
wir haben zwar kaum kampftruppen dafür
aber einen finanziell bestens
ausgerüstete berater armee
innovationsministerium da wurden munter
millionenbeträge für externe berater
ausgegeben für einzelne berater gab weit
über 200.000 euro für sage und schreibe
sieben monate arbeit stundensätze
zwischen 223 und 252 euro
purer filzen nehmen wird nun ein
untersuchungsausschuss im bundestag
nachgehen das wird auch zeit
das beste wissen sie wie von der leyen
nun in der berater affäre vorgehen
möchte kann man auch nicht drauf kommen
ist es aber so sie möchte in der berater
affäre tatsächlich weitere berater
einstellen die sie nun in der berater
affäre beraten sollen kein witz es war
berater für die berater affäre
das ergibt ungefähr so viel sinn als
selber feuer mit kerosin zu löschen
versuchte die stundensätze in neuen
berater sollen übrigens so hört man noch
über sein als die der alten da stellt
sich mir die frage werden die frau
eigentlich berät das ist so komplett
anders ich mich fragt hat sie ihren kopf
nur dazu dass zum hals nicht reinregnet
anders kann man gar nicht mehr erklären
das erkennen auch immer scherze machen
ich sehe das immer aus der perspektive
des steuerzahlers wir bezahlen dass wir
bezahlen all diesen irrsinn wohingegen
berater gebraucht hätte und
offensichtlich nicht hatte das ist ihre
doktorarbeit
denn der wurde tüchtig plagiiert ähnlich
wie wir kennen das alle noch bei annette
schavan bei frank walter steinmeier bei
zu guttenberg koch mehrin bei der
familienministerin gv alle schwierigkeit
mit dem zitieren also ich weiß nicht wie
das kommt ich sag ich habe ja selber ein
doktortitel und ich sage immer wenn ich
als politiker rede dass ich meine
doktorarbeit selbst geschrieben habe
weil das ist für politiker
offensichtlich nicht selbstverständlich
ist war mir aber so können die animation
ihren wird man so politiker ist so
einfach ich will da vielleicht etwas
altmodisch liebe freunde ich kommt zum
schluss findet ihr diesen jämmerlichen
zustand der deutschen politik über den
wir heute viel gehört haben traurig ich
auch aber ich will mal dagegen halten
es ist heute halt aschermittwoch de la
frontera sie nun vorbei und so schlimm
ist das gar nicht das bietet auch
chancen
es folgt die fastenzeit zeit für
besinnung und für fokussierung auf das
eigentlich auf das wesentliche zeit für
die vorbereitung auf das osterfest das
größte fest der christenheit ins
politische gewendet was vor uns liegt
ist sicherlich nicht heiter ist kein
zuckerschlecken leichte aufgaben gehen
anders überlassen wir bitte dieses land
nicht den merkels den haag sd nahles den
haarwuchs den seehofers und wie sie alle
heißen
[Applaus]
nehmen wir ihn schritt für schritt das
heft des handelns aus der hand und das
geht in einer demokratie nur mit
wahlerfolgen wir waren bis jetzt sehr
erfolgreich und ich prophezeie wir
werden noch viel erfolgreicher sein was
unser land nämlich braucht und dass
wissen immer mehr menschen und verstehen
immer mehr menschen das ist eine
konservativ freiheitlich patriotische
wende für die es nur mutige menschen mit
rückgrat mit herz verstand und moral
braucht die entgegen all der verleumdung
und der erbitterte widerstände ihren
mann stehen und ich auch ihre frau
schade dass die kathrin heute nicht da
sein kann eben das steiner gute
besserung von meiner adresse von rom aus
nochmal an die katrin
hallo männer und frauen die ihren mann
stehen lassen will ich das so sagen ich
bin ja noch nicht geändert wie sich vom
dekadenten zeitgeistigen mainstream
nicht kaputt kriegen und nicht in die
resignation treiben lassen denn das hat
dann mit uns vor und das wird nicht
gelingen dann und nur dann und nur mit
solchen leuten und nur so können und
werden wir die wende zu einer guten
zukunft unseres landes ich bin nach wie
vor von überzeugt tatsächlich noch
schaffen
am aschermittwoch so heißt es ist alles
vorbei für manche für wieder andere
läuft es darauf hinaus und sie zappeln
und wehren sich noch ein bisschen die
spd freut sich jetzt auch wir sind
gestiegen 23 prozent die freuen sich
jetzt wenn sich die 20 prozent marke
annähern für einen moment von unten
kommt das wird nicht lange bestand haben
dann haben sie die eins nicht mehr vorne
dann sind die einstellig genau darauf
hoffen die haut das nicht linear sondern
das niedergang der geht in solchen
oszillation jetzt sind die grad mal so
jetzt jubeln
jetzt geht es noch weiter runter für uns
aber liebe freunde für die alternative
für deutschland gilt und in bayern
allzumal am aschermittwoch
da fängt alles an in der europa- und bei
den kommunalwahlen nebenbei und weiter
dann in den drei ganz wichtigen
landtagswahlen im osten und im herbst
werden mit dem kaputten establishment
erneut zeigen dass sie uns mit ihren
ganzen verleumdung und mit ihrem ganzen
faulen tricks nicht klein kriegen und
erneut wird die kraft der besseren
argumente erneut wird die alternative
für deutschland siegen und das nächste
kapitel der so dringend notwendigen
wende für unser vaterland schreiben für
bayern für deutschland auf geht's liebe
freunde vielen dank für die
aufmerksamkeit